will Dungeons and Dragons honor among
Thieves while the natural 20 at movie
theaters or will it be a critical fail
no matter how the journey goes here's
what you need to know before venturing
out to seer
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
has been in the works for quite a while
and there's actually been a lot of drama
involved back in 2013 Warner Brothers
planned on making a Dungeons and Dragons
movie but there was a problem Dungeons
and Dragons Baron company Hasbro also
planned on making a film with universal
one lawsuit later everybody decided to
settle and Hasbro and Warner Brothers
joined forces to make the movie together
in 2015. so for a bit everything looked
like Smooth Sailing Ansel Elgort was
even cast as the lead but after a few
years of struggling to bring the project
to fruition the rights were awarded to
Paramount in 2017. the release of the
film kept getting moved around after
that with a theatrical debut of July 23
2021 getting changed three times before
landing on its final spot so when can we
finally expect to see honor among
Thieves play out on the big screen well
the fantasy adventure of the year is
almost here Marky calendars for March 31
who doesn't love a good heist movie and
if there's a bit of magic involved or
the better it seems that's exactly what
we're getting with Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves complete with mimics
owl bears and plenty of winged reptiles
the plot revolves around Edgar and The
Bard a Charming Thief with a penchant
for making plans but it's as seen in the
trailers it looks like edgkin isn't too
careful about who he's doing business
with truth be told
we helped the wrong person steal the
wrong thing thy greatest evil happens to
be zaztam a powerful red wizard who
wants to unleash an undead Army upon the
world to stop delicious diabolical plot
and the game will have to assemble a
ragtag bunch of Heroes which includes a
barbarian a paladin a sorcerer and a
druid and get his hands back on that
dangerous world-ending artifact of
course that's a lot easier said than
done with a whole slew of monsters and
mages running around
honor among Thieves boasts quite an
impressive cast of a-listers up and
coming stars and talented character
actors for the role of the Charming
Thief Edgar in the bud we've got perhaps
the most Charming actor in Hollywood the
one and only Chris Pine best known for
fares such as Star Trek hell or high
water and Wonder Woman Pine is the
perfect fit for a charismatic scoundrel
who can scheme and smile his way out of
any situation he'll be joined to this
Quest by Michelle Rodriguez as Holger
the Barbarian the bronzer Edkins brains
Rodriguez is no stranger to playing the
muscle as she's beaten up plenty of bad
guys and burned plenty of rubber as
Letty Ortiz in the Fast and Furious
franchise along the way Edgar and Holger
will be joined by zank the Paladin Simon
the Sorcerer And dorak The Druid so
who's playing this Motley Crew well zenk
will be portrayed by reggae Jean page of
Bridgeton Fame Simon is played by
Justice Smith of Jurassic world Fallen
Kingdom and Doric will be brought to
life by Sophia lilis of the it movies we
could also expect to see the king of the
rom-coming himself Hugh grants as fjorge
fits William the Rogue who looks to be
playing a character in the vein of Jeff
goldblum's Grandmaster from Thor
Ragnarok
at one point in the Dungeons and Dragons
timeline Chris McCay of The Lego Movie
and the tomorrow war was set to direct
however McKay stepped away from the
project in 2019 making room for two new
dungeon Masters Jonathan Goldstein and
John Francis Daly today they've only
directed Two films not counting on it
among Thieves their first effort was
2015's vacation starring Ed Helms and
Christina Applegate which earned a
measly 27 Rotten Tomatoes score their
other film however is a massively
underrated game night a comedy thriller
starring Jason Bateman and Rachel
McAdams in addition to directing the duo
has penned quite a few scripts including
comedies such as Horrible Bosses and
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs too
plus it helped co-write one of the mcu's
most popular films Spider-Man homecoming
so it should come as no surprise that
they co-wrote the honor among Thieves
script along with up-and-coming
screenwriter Michael gillio as you can
probably tell from all their
aforementioned credits Goldstein and
Daly are big on Comedy and they also
have experience in a world of action
adventure films watching the trailers
for Honor among Thieves you can see what
appears to be a perfect marriage between
those two Styles and we're pretty
excited to see what Goldstein and Daly
are bringing to the table here if the
existing plan fails I make a new plan so
you make plans that fail no he also
plays the loot not relevant created by
Gary gygax and Dave Anderson Dungeons
and Dragons has been around since 1974
and over the years it's created a
massive fan base needless to say fans
are always sensitive about their
favorite properties so when dark the
Druid morphed into an owl Bear drawing
an honor among Thieves trailer some
people were a little miffed according to
the rules a druid can't transform into
an Albert so the film clearly plans on
bending some of the long-established
gameplay mechanics speaking to ygn
director Jonathan Goldstein elaborated a
bit on the backlash saying we're aware
that there was a certain amount of
controversy that emerged in the DND fan
Community after the first trailer showed
our Druid wild shaping into an Albert
and it was something we discussed a
great deal when we were writing yeah so
why did the writers decide to include
something that went against d d Cannon
as a filmmaker further explained we
subscribe to the rule of cool and we
thought that we as the dungeon masters
of this movie would let our players do
this then why should we deprive the
audience of something as cool and
exciting as this however don't assume
Goldstein and Daley are going completely
row here in fact the two have been
working very closely with Wizards of the
Coast the company behind the popular RPG
speaking with collider producer Jeremy
lutchem explained they were very
involved in the actual design of the
Dragon it was tremendously weighed on a
ton of stuff in the lore but the dragons
themselves there was so much lore
specific stuff about exactly where the
Finn goes and exactly how the thumb
Works daily also confirmed their
dedication to the game saying our hero
dragon our red dragon is actually based
on a character in the lore so we're not
totally deviating from what people want
on that note they're also bringing a big
bad from DND lore the red wizard zaztam
although most everyone else's unique to
the movie as Goldstein explained to IGN
John and I really set out to make a
movie that captured the spirit of
playing a game of DnD we're not really
using any existing story or characters
this is pretty much all of our own
creation but we're putting in a world
that comes from 50 years of the law of
Dungeons and Dragons
uh figure it out over a drink probably
best
[Music]